seth how can we help hey guys how are
y'all doing today
oh we're having a blast what's going on
okay i've got a question for you guys um
i'm i'm 35 years old um
financially fairly stable um my question
is
how to balance the side jobs the side
gigs the
extracurricular work if you will and
family i've got two kids
um i've got a little boy that will be
four in july and one that will be one uh
in a month
um what's the what's the goal seth
what's the goal of this side work
to be debt-free i am so sick and tired
my wife and i both and we're we're both
on the same page
i'm tired of making monthly payments on
it how close
how close are you dangerously close
um the only debt that we have besides
the mortgage
is we owe about fifty eight hundred
dollars on a car
um so you're real close i mean
what's your payoff what's your payoff
date on the car if everything stays the
same
if we just if we just make the payments
as scheduled
um about uh 13 14 months something like
that no no
no i thought you were i thought you were
working really hard i'm saying with your
goal how long before you expect to pay
this off working all these side jobs
if everything goes according to plan
three four five months something like
that
um okay hold on a second hold on a
second
hold on keep on playing this out and
then how many more months to have that
three to six month emergency fund funded
probably another well with that extra
with the extra kick with the the car
payment being gone probably
three or four months okay so here's the
deal
i know a lot of men myself included who
did a lot of extra jobs
we told ourselves it was because of the
money but it really was because we were
insecure
we were awkward around our families or
our friends
and i was we are i was chasing
external validation so when someone
asked me to do something absolutely i'm
in
all right you need this thing i can do
that i can help with that and it was
constant movement movement movement
movement
and as you're feeling right now my my
family's the one that suffered for it
the other side of that is families often
sell themselves short you guys can do
anything for one two three four years
when you are
grinding out sprinting gazelle intense
towards a goal
and that's where you're at and it's
uncomfortable and you're watching these
precious moments of your kids slip
through your fingers some of that is
paying the piper for
as you said living a life that that you
couldn't afford
and you got to get caught up the other
side of that is brother you are
real real close what do you what do you
uh
how would you define out of balance
that's the crux of your question how do
i
how do i have balance and i want to know
where you feel the stress or the pain
of being out of balance describe that
briefly
the fact that and my wife feels like
in a sense that she's a single parent
you know because i work a lot um
you know i'm out of town so i'm not a
whole lot but some um
but you know i'm gone from the house
before eight every morning and lots of
times it's
8 39 9 30 10 o'clock at night before i
roll back up
and you know i saw my kids for
15 minutes in the morning and that's the
extent of my interaction with my
children got it yeah all right so
uh this is this is what i think you
should do i think you've got to sit down
by yourself and go can i keep this up
and do i think my wife can handle this
for
i think you said three or four more
months just to pay off the car
um that's a short-term sacrifice that i
think is gonna pay off
big time but i think if you're willing
to do it if your heart can handle it and
you think your wife can i would
i would determine that john first then
i'd sit down with the wife and go hey
i'm hearing you
and you know why i'm doing this but i'm
just gonna remind you i'm doing this for
us
um are you okay if i if we just bite the
stick and we bear down
uh for three four more months and at
that point i'll knock one of the jobs
off or you guys sit down and talk about
it and then you can slow down a little
bit
uh if you feel like your hearts can't
keep this up and and then it just takes
a little bit longer to get that
emergency fund going
um the other side of that is you know
reassess
you know some other ways that you might
be able to juice that emergency fund by
selling even more stuff you know you
guys know your budget you know your
situation but i
i think i would stay on the gazelle
intensity the way you're working right
now
until you get the car paid off take a
deep breath
maybe even find a better job could you
do
one job that pays what you're doing in
two extra jobs
start to just really get innovative and
creative
because i think we can always do that
when there's a will there's a way it's
an old phrase and i think that's really
true
and seth there is something magic about
sitting down with a calendar
and your wife and saying with a big red
pen saying this is when this ends
and you have to commit in and be a
person of integrity
and keep your word and say the day that
we cross this threshold
i'm quitting this job and you get your
husband back
and not only do you get your husband
back physically your presence there
but i'm going to be invested because i'm
not going to be running scared anymore
i'm going to be able to slow down and i
love what ken said that's when you start
able to thinking about man what's
another career look like we can make
some more money what uh what do we want
to do
who do we want to be now that we're done
sprinting to get away from this this
lion
yeah but i i love ken's advice man sit
down with your wife
with a calendar and say this is the end
of this you just told us
three four five months that's a big gap
brother and then another three four five
months to get your emergency fund
if you can tell me from right now six
months from today you are debt free and
you got a
an emergency fund and you can sit down
your wife and circle that big on the
calendar
and say after this is when we're going
on a trip we're going camp we're doing
something
man everybody can get through that
together but she's got to be super super
clear
seth real quick uh are you working seven
days a week five days a week six what
does it look like
it kind of depends so i i'm a welder and
i have a
quote day job um that is basically a
monday through friday gig
um some weekends but not and then i also
have my own equipment and i do some
freelance stuff some you know
yeah somebody needs something well do
they call me and i will fix it or you
know whatever
so roughly you got it you got you got at
least a saturday a couple times a month
where you're not working or you're
working every saturday
uh no i i make it a point at this at
this
time good to have some time to where
it's good us it's just our core family
and you know get off facebook and so
here's what i want you to hear from me
seth
everything john and i said still holds
but you know what you need to do
maybe you need to do laundry all day on
a saturday exactly right and actually
let her
not parent at all and yes that goes a
long way
yes you're tired do laundry anyway you
can handle it it's six more months you
got this
yep give her some relief not just be
home
all right good stuff thanks for the call
good good